welcome to this video playing pointe du
jour played him a number of times but
I'll relatively look right at you at the
moment it's bit surprised came he
declined the idea to to go to a de banco
so we have a palm of a techno and it is
a relatively you play the relatively
unambitious set up here that looks very
decent for Blackie no I'm threatening on
d4 and Knight a5 I don't really know if
this is so great forward the moment
thats a queen d 1 is the best move here
yeah
hmm
hmm this looks really really fishy but
is it working night XD form I mean
working for black night XD form MMF son
and I text you for that snide f7 as well
and this looks a bit strange really
maybe this is even good maybe that's
even good i mean there's also the c2
thing going on come on I do that now I
can can spend ages and at the end up
late anyway because I want to review
this and move like a success is okay but
it's not not really the way to to review
this type of joy this is what I saw and
here I thought I thought that it's it's
an overload of the Queen if it goes to
see for s-92 winning the rook and other
squares are take the bishop for 22
pieces to pieces against zerg
yeah I think it's just working I don't
don't see him any good move here yeah so
is there even something better then the
direct nights it would check I don't
think so move like beehive as
interesting still no cat let's just
let's just grab this however here may be
here there is some there are some
additional possibilities look do you
want as a move that could be a problem
because of my back rank here I wonder
light if I go b5 quindi high F is very
nice web b5 queen bee for a BF I've I
mean is very nice 94 and if the night
takes maybe I have some additional
possibilities then there's also be 595
Bishop a 6 that's also a good move come
on I don't really have my plan I don't
really trust night a1 rook d1 this looks
it looks very dangerous twin somewhere
but should be three I don't know this
also looks like an interesting move and
then move that is keeping the initiative
at least I hope 95 the bishop a success
my idea after Quincy to Bishop b5 check
is Bishop c4 actually that's probably
the drawback but anyway this thing
giving up the pawn is maybe not a bad
idea to open the blinds and this can be
helpful so night eggs okay it's doing
something else entirely interesting
though but here i have i have before
attending this check but it's got Bishop
c4 then okay but i can also i can just
take the bishop here let's let's not
forget simple things let's just grab the
bishop and i'm still attacking the rook
so here maybe queen to be 6 yep the
night is controlling you three if you
place Bishop e3 I'll just take that and
I'm perfectly okay and I'm threatening
probably be for him
yeah this looks very very tricky now in
probably Plex should win now really I've
got to two pieces and i have i have more
active possibilities really then he has
push herb f6 yeah but this is this
cheeky on a successor quite quite quite
an important point there's still a ton
of things hanging bishop is six first or
yeah well then i asked in d2 maybe queen
f6 Quincy 4b should be six okay and if
it rates queen through this there is
lots of stuff hanging the rook the blur
the night
yeah okay it really should be enough
check 95 I go queen like we should be
okay level out out of any ammunition
yeah that of course it all depends here
on this 94 mph does it working yet is
working and winning yeah I really I
couldn't really figure it out but I
thought that everything else must be
it's just second grader okay so let's
briefly consider i mean i thought this
this is what you played this I think
it's not working at all because now will
the Queen Hanks and there is no square
really something like this I can I can't
play Bishop f5 it's very very dangerous
yeah there are points like this I hadn't
calculated this I was just thinking okay
that it shouldn't really work so and
this this wasn't working to what
happened in the game right check check
yeah the computer wants to take and says
that this is a mistake yeah possible
possible it's just it's just so
complicated I wasn't after luke t one
here I wasn't really sure that nothing
bad is going to happen to me computer i
just placed this and says black windsor
but there is just if he gets in look da
damn checkmated and i wasn't i wasn't
really sure the big point is probably
that Queenie five he has a check so if
he does something like that I have
various or here I have checks and then
can move the bishop to secure the back
rank am I didn't see that I thought that
instead this is also interesting but it
turns out well this losses but it turns
out that this is still ok for Wyatt
according to the computer yeah one line
that are also this this is what I
originally thought and I thought I'm
winning but there's Bishop c4 this is
not clear at all
so what I would have done probably is to
take now and this is this is losing from
like is it yeah there's this additional
idea check check to do this sorry this
what was deck check giant white is
winning totally totally weird line yeah
alright thanks for watching